les séries un toc toc toc spécial
chanteurs et chanteuses ce culte on va
démarrer alors je vous dis on va
démarrer très fort parce que la tête du
gars là je vous le dis elle peut faire
peur elle peut faire rire mais elle ne
vous laissera pas indifférente
regardez ces partis toc toc toc non mais
attendez que mr on voit on voit que le
public à la cdo à l'étape attaqué à
sept-îles
il skie et venait d'avoir
[Musique]
dans
[Applaudissements]
maintenant quand
non
bien
[Applaudissements]
il m'a serré la main ce qu'on a du coup
j'ai pas les mains sales c'est ça depuis
tout à l'heure je suis vous les mettez
vous plaît mettez vous là bas ça va très
bien dans une forme olympique on demande
à ses conseillers vous vos gosses
faisant voici tout le monde à nous
écouter c'est vous qui me déguiser comme
ça c'est pas moi ça me va très bien et
la jambe apparente est magnifique
franchement c'est très beau merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sans voiture basse tout le monde
bon d'accord c'est parti deuxième du top
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
elle reconnaît plus personne à arida
[Musique]
terrible
[Applaudissements]
ces démarches ont pris la ville on sait
jamais la bise
bravo mais en tout cas elle a donné un
nom mais elle donne bien vous allez donc
vous je vous le dis vous allez sortir
déjà oui kelly vous le dirai peut-être
un jour
non mais on avait toujours on a vécu des
choses difficiles aux loges si vous n'y
avez jamais castaldi voilà pas vous en
dire plus du mythe mohamed est également
témoin
je suis pas sûr matière aux
téléspectateurs d'habitude je vous dit
tout mais là non pour le bien de la
suite de sa carrière je ne suis pas sûr
maintenant qu'on vient dire quoi moi je
couds que le dire ah oui à la fin de
l'émission
ah oui vous balance toi aujourd'hui on
peut en parler avant quand même parce
que non mais moi je dis ça pour lui moi
je m'en fous un bon va très bien elle va
balancer elle va balancer écouter à mon
avis ce soir vous ne rentrerez pas chez
vous
merci allez c'est parti isa baba version
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
toi
je commence à s'adapter c'est la cg je
vais chez jet suis libertine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moussavi
[Musique]
alors arrêtez de croire qu'une maquette
ou une mamie en fait devenu ouf elle
allait elle était partant celle annoncée
du mouvement
les abeilles connaît le meilleur donc de
fil des missions
allez on y va
paul buck toc toc thaçi c'est comme
comme corps comme les rois mages
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
rires
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais les moulins du monde
mais dis moi tu t'es pas du tout déguisé
toi mais je kiffe sheila diouf je reste
fort et benghazi alors là je sais qu
elle cette couleur un poil plus clair ah
oui ça tirait très bien avancé ça on
saurait ce qui parle
oui là c'est le color caméras les
mecquois persil reste
à laisser partir a dit c'est qui la tac
tac tac d'asile bien lancés çà et saliha
timbre apposé même salaire vas-y toc toc
toc pierre clament l'amérique la nuit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
nous
[Applaudissements]
bonjour plus fort
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je n'ai plus pas jeter mes 40 ans depuis
que je suis née qui ça l'amérique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Rires]
bravo maxime guennoun dévoilé cette
barque à la maxime d'innisfail
merci au dr king n'est faire à tour de
chant à las vegas d'une heure et demie
allez c'est parti
toc toc toc toc toc par avance quelqu'un
qui aime l'humour de l'anah mois mille
colombes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mireille que j'aime c'est pour moi une
des plus belles femmes du monde
ouais ils les croisés et elle m'a dit
qu'elle vous adorez et qu'elle avait
hâte
[Rires]
j'ai travaillé mais c'est le mec qui
sait pas il est atteint vite accro et
mireille mathieu et sa soeur je les
adore elle adore l'émission elle m'a dit
qu'elle regardait tous les soirs et moi
que vous êtes avec nous sur la spéciale
charles aznavour mireille mathieu il ya
du très loin et elle est magnifique mais
j'ai trouvé ce numéro 9 des deux années
de tensions a les deux soeurs la
glissade d'or mais c'est vrai que
l'équipe ii ou médaille d'or cette
famille vraiment vous étiez avec elle
hier vous avez des jeunes est battu mais
moi je les adore tout ouais ok mireille
ses deux soeurs tout le temps mais quoi
que toutes les murailles de france
allez on y va c'est parti alors au toc
toc ciel et marine bellechasse
[Applaudissements]
pour toi
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu peux tu entré dans le bar d'un café
noir les parties à l'ets le fossat audi
va aller marilou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui ils voient pas qu'ils aient
des cas décalé mais je chante une
juriste off car yahoo
[Applaudissements]
magas à l'eau c'est le plus haut depuis
mai mais c'est le poussant de plus
départ est un choc isabelle and on vous
dira la halle avec jamel c'est un mode
délire là ça allait trop touchy
jean-michel leslie laisser les rênes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
genre
papa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
abattoir pardon dont claude tu veux je
vais m'excuser auprès de claude famille
ses amis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
manger du budget alors là c'est la
réponse du berger à verser la route